- My four hours in
Portugal were amazing.
Just in and out, hard-core
just an amazing
country that I wish
I got to spend a little more
time in but you'll see the chaos
and tomorrow is the first
original weekend DailyVee
which I'm filming right now.
So a little preview.
("Duality" by Jeremy Kingg)
I'm supposed to be
on stage in 20 minutes.
Yes, I'm the keynote speaker.
Gary Vaynerchuk.
He's with me as well.
- [Man] I got ticket.
- We did it.
I'll do some.
I'm in good shape.
I just got off a flight.
I got strong.
(audience applause)
You have to deal with
the reality of the situation.
Dwelling and pondering
and crying doesn't do shit.
And it especially doesn't do
shit in this echo chamber.
In this arena,
there is no crying.
You can cry,
you're just gonna lose.
And I have bad news about
complaining and crying.
Let me tell you something about
complaining and crying that's
really, really gonna hurt for
all you complainers out there.
Nobody gives a shit.
(audience applause)
It's here.
It's upon us and now we
have to, more than ever,
we have to start
deploying self-awareness.
If you leave here and start your
process of really knowing what
makes you happy, if you want to
actually do something even in
the light of the picture that
I'm painting right now who are
you scared to fail in front of?
The reason so many of you are
not doing what you want
to do is you're scared,
you're scared that your
brother will judge you,
your wife, your girlfriend,
your husband and
most scary your mom or your dad.
You need to eliminate that
and or own that fear and put
yourself in a
position to succeed.
And a lot of people need to hear
one of two things today which is
this is the greatest era to ever
be alive and be an entrepreneur
or executive if you want it and
stop complaining and dwelling
'cause nobody gives a fuck.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
Yes, a coconut.
Can you imagine?
Ooph.
- [Woman] That was a good one.
- [Gary] That was a good one.
Oh, we're going to a
whole different place?
- [Woman] Yeah.
We're just gonna
drive you over there.
It's a bit of a walk.
(audience applause)
- Go back and look at what
happened in the late 40s and
early 50s when our society
went away from being a primary
television, a radio society to
an emerging television society.
A lot of people, a lot of power,
a lot of brands died and a lot
have emerged and that's what
we're about to live through
over this next decade.
As we shift to the phone
being our primary news,
content, information platform
we will have people that are
romantic and holding onto
the old world and they'll die.
And we'll have new people that
execute and story tell on the
new platform and emerge
as more important figures,
organizations and causes.
'Cause every time there's
something new we have an
inability as people to apply
historic rules to it and we're
scared of the new thing.
We go into defense.
Again, this is what we did on
TV forever and back to Vine,
let me tell you about the 50
people that went all-in on Vine.
They're making millions of
dollars a year on branded
content on
Snapchat and Instagram.
They made a good call while you
debated if it was
going to be around.
(audience applause)
Let's go.
- [Man 2] Let's go.
- [Gary] You're on video.
- [Man 2] I'm on video.
So Antonio Media.
- [Gary] Dude, I thought we
were going to do a picture.
You're fucking
putting me on video?
- [Man 2] Wait,
wait, wait, let's go,
right here.
- [Gary] Alright, got to go.
Good to see you guys.
I got to go.
I'm sorry.
Alright, fast, fast, let's go.
I looked at your
face, it made me sad.
Jets, baby.
- [Crowd] Gary!
- [Gary] Thank you.
Thank you, so much.
Bye guys.
No, this is this.
- Okay.
- [Man 3] Fucking A man.
- [Gary] Dude, it's
getting so crazy.
- [Man 3] You're
like a fucking--
- [Man 4] I snuck in.
- We'll just got
your suitcase maybe.
- [Gary] I'm gonna be
late for me flight.
I'm sorry, man.
I'm so sorry.
Come on, run.
- [Man 3] Yes, yes.
- [Gary] Yes.
It's cool?
- [Man 3] Of course,
it's cool, Gary.
- [Gary] Alright, can you
tell him to stop for one second?
- [Man 5] Thank you, Gary.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
Real fast.
- [Both] Awesome.
- [Gary] Hi.
- Hi.
- Sure.
- Oh, thank you so much.
I love you, I love you...
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
Take care.
- Thank you my friend.
- No worries.
Of course, let's do it.
- Thank you.
- Great presentation.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you, man.
- What an amazing
experience you gave us.
("Rokit" by Jeremy Kingg)
- Awesome.
Bye guys.
- [Man 6] All together.
All together.
- You can cut him out.
- Thanks man.
- Awesome.
You got it.
- Five words for success?
- [Gary] You're gonna
die, I did that one.
Hustle baby, it's patience.
When you're young,
all of you guys fuck up because
you want it so bad too soon.
I didn't do, I fucking worked 20
hours a day until I was 30 and
didn't talk to anybody.
Waited.
- Thank you man.
- You guys want it today.
- Yes.
- You got to wait.
How old are you?
- I'm double your age.
- Like you live a whole other
fucking life and you're my age.
And you want it tomorrow,
you got to put in real work.
You're not gonna
come up with some idea.
Real work.
- Do you think that the
knowledge you get at university
would be helpful
in the real world?
- [Gary] No.
But if you want to
get a job, yeah,
but not if you're
building businesses.
- [Man 7] I tell my
parents I fucking quit, bro.
- [Gary] Alright.
Ready?
- [Man 7] Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome
guys, take care.
(crosstalk)
- [Gary] Okay.
Matt, this guy's sister doesn't
have her passport or something,
we got to throw him
in the car somehow.
Bye guys.
One second.
21.